les caprices de la nature qui laisse
faute de pluie des régions dépérir de
ses chasses quand d'autres souffrent
d'inondations sont peut-être sur le
point d'être corrigés c'est dans cette
perspective en tout cas que se situe
l'expérience de lannemezan où le
professeur d'essence a installé son
météo tron l'appareil a fabriqué les
nuages le métier autres ont une centaine
de brûlures reliés par 700 mètres de
tuyaux à des réservoirs contenant trois
tonnes de gasoil en somme le modèle
géant du dispositif employés dans les
chaudières à mazout
l'allumage évidemment est un peu plus
compliqué et c'est tout mais l'histoire
ne s'arrête pas là une énorme source de
chaleur se trouvent ainsi créée elle va
amorcer le processus de formation d'un
cumulus qui soit dit en passant n'aura
rien à voir avec les fumées parasites
dégagée par la combustion
l'air surchauffé aspirant l'air humide
ambiant à 20 km à la ronde va s'élever à
100 ou 200 kilomètres à l'heure
jusqu'aux zones d'air froid et sec ou va
s'opérer la condensation qui fera naître
un cumulus
désormais donc un cumulus fenêtre là où
l'homme en aura décidé c'est là la
révolution apportée par les expériences
de lannemezan où des radars spéciaux
permettent de suivre la formation du
nuage il suffit alors d'une projection
dieu dur d'argent sur ce nuage pour le
faire tomber rampe lui
la première étape d expérience s'est
ainsi révélé concluant le mettais autres
on a réussi à remplacer la nature ou
plutôt à lui forcer la main demain
l'homme de science pourra laisser la
place aux faiseurs de pluie et il sera
enfin possible de produire à volonté à
la terre la plus sèche sa part
d'humidité et de fertilité
[Musique]